on a une question de la voix de
secretstory s'il avoue avoir les preuves
les passants ya l'eau à la bouche
bonjour la voix de montoir abbas et la
vraie monnaie c'est la vrai moi c'est
dominique duforest la vraie voix à la
fois physiquement cyclades stories avait
une question pour qui dominique et merci
d'être avec nous en tout cas
alors logiquement merci logiquement la
voix une question qu à jamais benjamin
le béni yes qui s'est réjoui les
audiences de secret story
beh ce que de tout dans mon époque si
lointaine déjà voici la question de la
voix te réjouis tue souvent du malheur
des autres tout pour le moment
[Applaudissements]
c'est chaud chaud
alors attendez attendez vous allez
répondre merci d'avoir en tout cas
d'avoir participé par radioactu la mer
c'est la mer
alors alors je me réjouis pas du malheur
des autres dans le cas de ces crêtes je
vous il ya une chose évidemment que par
orgueil on est très content quand vous
quittez une émission les plus dans le
programme que l'émission se casse la
gueule
évidemment que ça m'a fait un plaisir
immense mais je vous dis évidemment on
n'a pas envie une émission que vous avez
quittez vous survive je trouve que j'ai
quitté deux fois dans ma vie un afro
cram
j'avais quitté nouvelle star qui après
mon départ à l'arrière on a fini très
bien écrit jean hily après ça c'est que
c'est la figure et d' enquête secrète
c'est pareil alors j'ai toujours dénoncé
j'aimais qui du programme ou de
l'animateur est plus fort mais le fait
est que voilà donc dans ces deux cas
précis j'étais content que après moi ça
se casse la gueule